as we look forward out of the coded 19
pandemic governors in some states are
already talking about reopening some
businesses and a few states have already
started reopening social distancing must
continue but our economic shutdown
cannot South Carolina's business is
business people want to work they need
to work we will allow gyms fitness
centers bowling alleys to reopen their
doors but rushing to reopen too early
could lead to a deadly a second wave the
first and the biggest mistake we can
make is ending physical distancing too
early if we rush to reopen it could lead
to the uncontrolled spread of the virus
all over again it won't be safe to
reopen until we see a dramatic decline
in the number of cases there isn't a
magic number in terms of how big that
decline in cases needs to be and
different countries are handling that
differently the White House is saying
that states should be looking for a
decline in cases for 14 straight days
because that's the virus's incubation
period but China didn't allow cities
like Wuhan and Nanjing and others to
reopen until intense surveillance
detected zero new cases for 14 days
overall a second wave in China seems to
be pretty minimal at the moment here in
the states and in some countries in
Europe the virus is still reaching its
peak we're still waiting to see an
overall decline in cases in the state
signaling that the virus spread is
slowing and that potential future
outbreaks won't overwhelm hospitals it
will take several more stages until we
return to some kind of normal some
experts predict that we could see some
level of physical distancing continue
for years
[Music]
the next big mistake would be not
preparing hospitals for another surge
we've seen this happen in the past
take the 1918 Spanish flu pandemic that
killed an estimated 50 million people
and many of those didn't die in the
first wave of the pandemic they were
killed in the second and third waves
given that another surge of kovat 19 is
likely we need to make sure that
hospitals have three things the first is
medicines that are proven to treat this
virus right now in some cases doctors
are using experimental treatments but we
need antivirals that specifically target
this new corona virus second we need the
right amounts of personal protective
equipment or PPE for our first
responders and our health care workers
so that we're not seeing a situation
like we are now in this first wave where
people are having to reuse PPE or having
to use expired masks it's so important
that our frontline health care workers
have that protective equipment to make
sure they're safe while caring for
others and to limit the spread of the
virus through health care facilities and
third we need to make sure that
hospitals have sufficient resources and
equipment that means everything from
enough beds enough staff and ventilators
to treat the sickest patients the third
critical mistake would be to reopen
without ramping up testing dramatically
the need for accurate widely available
and quick turnaround testing could be
the most important factor in reopening
the country without accurate testing we
just have no idea of how far and wide
this virus has spread and also it means
we can't diagnose people quickly and
treat them appropriately this is
especially important given that as many
as one in four people who has the
disease doesn't show any symptoms and in
that context of a symptomatic spread it
means we need to continue testing even
as the number of cases declines and we
may need to test people multiple times
one of the challenges of this new virus
is we don't know how long immunity lasts
for or what the likelihood of
reinfection might be so far we've tested
four million mmm
Ekans and are running between 130,000 to
160,000 tes a day but we should be
running 500,000 to 700,000 tests a day
but ramping up testing to this extent
could cost billions of dollars add to
that the challenge that you're asking
lab technicians to suddenly do many many
more tests on top of their existing work
you're taking away resources from other
areas in the healthcare field and at the
exact same time the entire world is also
demanding access to these resources the
next big mistake we could make is
letting the virus spread without
tracking it so basically not doing
contact tracing contact tracing is where
we find each person who has the disease
find out when they were contagious and
then trace their steps to find out where
they went and who they had contact with
while they were infectious and then you
have to follow up with each and every
one of those contacts to make sure
they're quarantined or isolated as
necessary it's an old-school Public
Health technique but let me tell you
contact tracing has been the cornerstone
of every major infectious disease
epidemic investigation a lot of contact
tracing is legwork you're following up
with people finding out where they went
and who they may have exposed but there
are new tools that can help Apple and
Google are working on contact tracing
technology for smartphones but keep in
mind as important as contact tracing is
it really has to work hand-in-hand with
widespread testing without knowing who's
been infected
we can't monitor the spread
[Music]
and finally we need to stop repeating
the panic neglect cycle the panic
neglect cycle is what we so often see in
public health where we offer freak out
during the crisis and then soon after we
forget about it and act like nothing bad
happened the aftermath of the 2002 2003
SARS pandemic is a perfect example of
this panic neglect cycle a possible
vaccine for SARS was being developed but
then it was abandoned by funders as the
disease tapered off so then we ended up
with a half developed SARS vaccine that
was forgotten about in laboratory
freezers the panic neglect cycle
especially that panic part of it also
leads to what we call exceptionalism
where we target much of our funding and
energy on one disease but at the cost of
other pressing diseases I'm hearing of
some people losing jobs our other
medical organizations for example those
working on dementia because they're
losing funding during this pandemic but
dementia is not going anywhere and so we
need to make sure that we don't lose
focus of all those other diseases that
cause so many problems also Ebola is
still not fully under control and so
even though it's not making headlines
right now we can't take our eye off the
ball and I really hate that after all
the panicking we fall into this neglect
mode because it's really not a matter of
if we'll go through this again it's a
matter of when will we go through this
again and we need to be prepared for it
and we need to learn from this so that
we don't keep repeating our mistakes
thank you so much for watching keep
dropping your comments here and
contacting me on social media stay home
and stay safe everyone
[Music]